To get x by itself, and come up with our solutions, we need to get rid of our
exponent. So, we need to take the square root of both sides. Taking the square
root of x squared just gives us x, and on the right side, we need to take the
positive and negative versions of the square root of negative 9. Now, let's
think about what to do with this radical and the number underneath it. We can
rewrite negative 9 as negative 1 times 9 and as we learned before, if we have
two factors both written under a radical sign, we can apply the radical to both
of them individually, just like we can with exponents. So now, we have plus or
minus the square root of negative 1 times the square root of 9. Now, the square
root of negative 1 is just i, and the square root of 9 is just 3. So, our answer
is plus or minus 3i. Remember, that this means that if we substitutes in either
3i or negative 3i in place of x, it will satisfy our equation.